e aí galera que assistimos à nato gols e
espero que sim porque combinam muito bem
com a galera do em minas gerais em
varginha e muito frio a especial que
mora em vargem vai dizer sim não mas é
que nem é tão frio assim aqui no ciep
cara você não sabe o que é calor não eu
moro no lugar mais quente do brasil se o
kaká é a pessoa vai perguntar mas você
não é roupa de filme ou sei lá o quê
roupa de frio nem o céu não tenham a
única roupa que eu tenho que te mando
cumprida essa daqui hoineff não é a
pessoa que falam hoje eu vi na previsão
do tempo que vai fazer 29 graus hoje vai
fazer um calor lá meu deus 29 grau de
callao onde jesus galera quando vai 29
grau em teresina tocou para arrumar
chinelo tá com medo é da fogueira no
piauí e 29 graus já estou esperando e
pimba e da rohde tão freak tá é até
engraçado fico um pouco mais frio em
teresina o que é a rede começa a sentir
aquele cheiro de naftalina o povo pega
aquela blusa de frio que guarda no
inverno passado não é sério eu assumo eu
gosto de frio não tem o costume de frio
quando foi um pouco mais difícil no
piauí eu já saio na rua paraná centro
nesses aquelas fumacinha invadir e era
marrom pior disso tudo é que eu não
durmo ser ventilado e aqui já é muito
feio você pensa assim não hesitar porque
você não tá nem aí nem tempo de software
que eu gosto e ventilador causa do
barulho atual insiste em colocar o
equador morrendo de frio à noite toda só
que frio é um corpo muito bonito que eu
vou morrer assim muito longe novamente
já não é isso a cada noite que minas
gerais vou morrer um pouco mais amor
gostoso tá arrependido poucas sociedade
sofria
você vai ver a previsão do tempo vai
fazer calor não vai fazer calo caboclo
vai fazer os emos sabe que só você ter
uma idéia nem franco está fazendo a
divisão pra ver qual é o desafio a
tentarem tal cidade na época fala assim
pomba-gira vai pra espírito santo e
leste o tranca rua que chover teresina
não não não não não teresina não cara o
aluguel é tão quente que eu tenho
impressão que o sol não se põe ele só se
esconde para fazer planos maléficos para
ver o que ele vai fazer com o piauí é
esse eu vou ficar mais um dia aqui eu
espero que eu sobrevivi até lá
muito obrigado a todos vocês me ajudar
nessa caminhada eu quero que você comete
aqui embaixo que você prefere se você
prefere frio ou calor e conforto lugar
mais quente você já foi e qual foi o
lugar mais frio você já foi aquela coisa
não tô aqui pra entreter vocês e vocês
estão aqui para me ajudar
deixe que ele jóia que aquele jogo é
muito importante pra mim é a primeira
vez que você está aqui
esses vídeos do canal cíclica inscrever
se tiver virou você vai saber
em alguns vídeos no canal dá pra se dar
uma olhada e eles sabem é que eu sempre
investir no canal eu sempre estou
tentando fazer alguma coisa agora é o
após alguns meses atrás da compensa
câmera aqui para deixar a imagem mais
legal pra vocês e agora estou no pan de
comprar um microfone para ela então não
a visitá-la na canon eo link é o
primeiro link que está aqui na descrição
do vídeo explica lá comprando por este
link embaixo até o pouso você copia que
ele ocupou o campo neste link você tem
10% de desconto qualquer coisa que você
compra na loja então é nóis falam e as
redes sociais tac também na descrição do
vídeo em baixo do link da canon é meu
twitter no instagram facebook quem
quiser me seguir é bom que você siga por
acaso o youtube de alguma coisa não
enviou o vídeo para você você vai ver
agora essas redes sociais eu sempre
posta o print sem dúvida está dando
sempre posto é reposta no facebook na
minha página e no no meu perfil também e
também sempre posta no twitter twitter
também sou muito ativo quem quiser me
seguir lá vamos lá ver e mexer muito
frio e não tenho que malhar e nem sei o
que eu esqueci uma consigna rimar
falando com a bênção de chuva a deus só
rasgante estudo divulgado ontem menção
no texto